good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm ben dominic
401 years ago this month a group of
courageous pilgrims crossed the atlantic
on a ship seasoned from years of service
in the english channel their ship was
the mayflower it bore a people with
characteristics bold daring
foolish devout essential to the founding
of a new nation that would become the
envy of the world
the year was 1620. europe was beginning
a 30-year religious war that would raise
its cities starve its citizens unleash
plagues and take kings they set their
backs to the old ways and bet their
lives and their families on america
what started in plymouth changed the
world and changed it for the better it
was an audacious effort a group of
zealous religious men and women who put
all their resources behind creating a
new community and a new land foreign to
them in every way they might as well
have been the first explorers to set
foot on mars
these characteristics are essential to
understanding the american founding and
provide the basis for so much of what
makes this country great
the new york times's 1619 project and
its award-winning and controversial
creator nicole hannah jones are out with
a book this week
it is not worth addressing because it is
self-refuting when you assemble an
entire project around the demonstrably
false idea that preserving slavery was
the primary motivation for the american
revolution around the audacious claim
that our true founding is 1619 not 1776
and then retract or eliminate both
claims while pretending they were never
made there is little more others can add
except to acknowledge what is by now
plain for all to see the purpose of the
1619 project is not to teach history but
to propagandize the true american
founding is in 1776 and there should be
no historical dispute about it the ideas
assembled in that singular year were of
such a unique combination and importance
in human history you must play
contrarian games to insist otherwise but
i suggest to you the truth about 1620
amidst a time of constant historic
revisionism is that it represents not
just a convenient myth about the nation
but something that was essential to our
founding we find that in the risk-taking
character of the people who cross the
wine dark sea of the atlantic mindful of
all the courage it would take to
navigate a new world filled with
enormous potential for disease and death
we find it in their deeply held
religious beliefs rejecting church
hierarchy and rules as contrary to
scripture in favor of a world where you
need not go through another to come
before god and worship and where they
could raise their children in their own
faith instead of losing them and we find
it in their sheer audacity a group of a
few more than a hundred less than half
of them grown men so committed to an
idea and a belief in the rightness of
their purpose that they would flout any
pressure any government any restriction
even from the high monarch of england
james the first
the mayflower compact written in
anticipation of potential conflict and
disunity upon their landing made a nod
to king james in its opening
and made clear that the group would bow
only to such a government and governors
as we should by common consent agree to
make and choose it is a simple document
to read today simple but powerful it
represents an assumption of equality
under the law that would stretch from
that moment into the future
along the way the pilgrims encountered
one disaster after another before they
turned west they tried to head for
holland and were betrayed by the captain
they hired when the men escaped on a
ship their wives and children were
imprisoned they worked menial jobs while
their plans fell through again and again
before the journey began
and when they arrived they came upon a
land ravaged by plague thrust into the
onset of a harsh and unforgiving winter
before the spring half of them would be
dead
but what the pilgrims represented
together was a community with the
attributes willing to go on an errand
into the wilderness they believed as
hebrews 11 told them that they were
strangers and exiles on the earth
seeking a country of their own that was
a country god would prepare for them if
they were bold enough to seek it
these ideas did not just come from
europe as the great calvin coolidge said
101 years ago on the 300th anniversary
of the pilgrim's arrival at plymouth
rock they came not merely from the
shores of the old world it will be in
vain to search among recorded maps in
history for their origin they sailed up
out of the infinite there was among them
small trace of the vanities of life they
came undecked with orders of nobility
they were not children of fortune but of
tribulation persecution not preference
brought them hither but it was a
persecution in which they found a stern
satisfaction they cared little for
titles still less for the goods of this
earth but for an idea they would die
measured by the standards of men of
their time they were the humble of the
earth measured by later accomplishments
they were the mighty
in appearance weak and persecuted they
came rejected despised an insignificant
band in reality strong and independent a
mighty host of whom the world was not
worthy destined to free mankind no
captain ever led his forces to such a
conquest oblivious to rank yet men trace
the to them their lineage as to a royal
house and those of us who love this
country still do
my mother has a little wooden chair that
has been passed down in her family for
generations it's taller once a high
chair but it was cut down and used as a
tool to help a child learn to walk its
back is flat from the wear of little
hands the likeliest owner was jedediah
strong born on may 7th 1637 in plymouth
massachusetts to abigail and john strong
who married after crossing the atlantic
jedediah born under the governorship of
william bradford would go on to marry
freedom woodward who bore a daughter
they named thankful and began a line of
americans who would fight and serve
through all our wars french and indian
revolutionary civil and on to iraq and
afghanistan all the way up until today
our nation in the creed it represents is
under constant assault from the forces
of revisionism backed in a culture war
by woke corporations big tech and the
most malevolent forces within our media
all seeking to deny our inheritance
destroy our past forget the faces of our
fathers and demolish the value of the
courage and dedication at the heart of
america's creation that's why it's
incumbent upon us as americans to renew
this spirit in every generation not to
sit back on what prior generations built
but to strive out into the wilderness
ourselves the areas of life on this
corner of god's creation still
undiscovered un
contested and unclaimed
as the late great richard john newhouse
said it
why do we want everybody to work and
everybody to participate
because it's premised upon not just a
vacuous notion of freedom but a very
deep respect
for what um to quote one of my favorite
political philosophers john paul ii the
pope calls the subjectivity of society
the sheer magnificent diversity of human
beings when they are free to imagine and
to love and to associate the kind of
thing that tocqueville came in the 1830s
and saw in america and he saw the whole
future of the world
not without some shadowed aspects very
deeply shadowed but he saw a kind of
promise of a new way that he called
democracy and we uh for better and for
worse and all undeserving on our part we
represent that took billion possibility
for the human body
what a wondrous thing it is to see the
world that thanks to their courage and
faith pilgrims made for all its flaws
his humanity itself is flawed
it is a testament to their resolve and
daring without which the country and the
people we love
so much would not exist
for this we can and should be thankful